Hello everybody
my name is Chica
and I'm sniffing this bug that's been dead for months
I smell something stinky.... smells like a human hasn't showered in a while
hm
oh
give me food
damn
I am already faster than you
I am stronger
(It's just music btw)
Aren't I the cutest lil' pup
I am (not) okay with this! Get this stuff off of me!
hey audience
Can I be the new member of The Wiggles
Patty cake
Sn0Rf
The FitnessGram Pacer Test is a multistage aerobic capacity test that progressively gets more difficult as it continues. The 20 meter pacer test will begin in 30 seconds. Line up at the start. The running speed starts slowly but gets faster each minute after you hear this signal bodeboop. A sing lap should be completed every time you hear this sound. ding Remember to run in a straight line and run as long as possible. The second time you fail to complete a lap before the sound, your test is over. The test will begin on the word start. On your mark. Get ready!… Start. ding
adding subtitles harder than you think
I'm glad that I have Mark to keep me in shape
uhhh are you doing this right?
Could I get some uhhhh
PERSONAL SPACE HERE
Why DADDY WHY
>:(
It's okay
I still love you
okay maybe not
stop laughing at me
someone plz send help
what are you doing
sigh
yep I guess this is normal
I'm still a happy pup
you can stop now
STOP NOW PLEASE
thank you
ImMa GeTcHa
I am speed.
Intermission
bitch you thought
wEeeEeeeEEEEEEEEEEE!! There I go!
wait
hold on I have a scratch
I'm so pretty
MUWHAHAH I hit you in ur nards
*pausing this randomly just so I can see Chica's face is the best*
WoRmIpLiEr
imma getcha part 2
Aren't I the best??
Wow that's embarrassing haha that was a lot of drool
ah more drool
OOF
all i get is 2 pats for doing all that work?
hmm I see how it is
bye lmao
Bu-Bye!!!!
BOAT DOG OUT
wuff that was ruff